it's official after a decade django and
samuel l.jackson have been reunited kind
of not really not at all
Django Unchained
so Django Unchained is another
three-hour movie written and directed by
Quentin Tarantino this time it's a
Western stylistically speaking anyway it
would be a Western or a spaghetti
western but geographically speaking it
would actually be a southern when you
think about it
he's dabbled into some spaghetti western
style before with Kill Bill but now it's
a straight-up Western the plot of this
movie is Christoph volts comes across
Django and he's like alright hey I'm a
bounty hunter if you help me get these
guys I will help you and through a
series of circumstances they then agree
to go get Django's wife from Leonardo
DiCaprio I have trimmed a lot off of
that plot premise because it's a three
hour Tarantino movie but that is the
gist of it I've been looking forward to
this movie I'm a Tarantino fan luckily
this movie is pretty cool doesn't matter
if Santa got lost on the way to your
house he came to the movie theater
anyway a lot works in this movie first
of all we have Jamie Foxx's Django he's
a badass he's a slave who has become a
bounty hunter under the mentorship of
Christoph vault right there I could give
you that pitch and that would be enough
there's a lot more coming my friends
it's cool seeing him go from this really
timid slave to a really confident badass
he's a really fast pistol shot dude the
violence the violence Tarantino violence
is just it's just awesome it's that
mortal combat type extreme violence it's
just fun to see on the big screen I
don't know why when a pistol can blow
someone back through a wall in a
Tarantino movie yeah why not
that does put a smile on my face there
is some brutality in this movie not all
of it's enjoyable some of it you're like
yeah that's rough but I do love
Tarantino for this he is such an
unapologetic writer and director he
makes content he throws it on screen
most other writers or directors to be
like I'm going to take that out because
that's not really socially acceptable
Tarantino makes it does not apologize
for it that is rare in the filmmaking
business hats off to him for that and
moving on to some of the other
characters you have Leonardo DiCaprio
he's a total dick in this movie there
are certain roles that you're like oh
yeah I could see you Leonardo DiCaprio
doing any one of these roles for some
reason this role in Django Unchained I
didn't think to myself yeah one day Leo
DiCaprio is going to
do a roll like that I don't know why
it's such a Hollywood golden boy that
seeing him as a slave owning dick you're
like it's culture shock he plays this
role up you can tell us fun with it I
think that's what I love about Tarantino
movies everyone on screen looks like
they're just having a blast
is he a villain in this movie absolutely
arguably the villain in this movie
however is he the villain in this movie
or is samuel l.jackson the villain in
this movie samuel l.jackson is one of
those trusty type house slaves you know
those dudes are like no I'm better than
all the other slaves so they boss other
slaves around and he totally brown noses
with DiCaprio he's such a dick a dick to
the point where I'm like I don't know if
he's more of a dick than DiCaprio you
really can't tell here's some
perspective for you all right Jamie Foxx
is fantastic in this movie there's no
arguing that but of the scene stealer
samuel l.jackson steals every scene he's
in and he'll be in a scene with Leonardo
DiCaprio who steals every scene he's in
and he'll be in a scene with Christoph
Waltz who steals every scene he's in
three guys all steal every scene they're
in are in scenes together does that blow
your mind it should it'll be a sloppy
mess or a stroke of genius luckily this
is just genius and you can argue that
this movie as Tarantino movies do tend
to do does drag on a bit you're like
only the movie was shorter than it would
be perfect but then I was asking myself
when I was thinking about this review I
was like all right what scene would I
cut out of the movie and I couldn't
think of anything that I really would
have trimmed out of the movie which my
point of view is if you cannot think of
and properly conjure a counterexample
then there's no problem to begin with
it's just the fact that you don't like
long movies there are three types of
people in this world people who just
don't like Tarantino movies period and
the other two are people who say that
Kill Bill is better than inglorious
basterds are people who consider
inglorious basterds better than Kill
Bill yeah Tarantino's earlier [ __ ] is
like his Golden Age nothing's gonna
touch that for me I felt Django
Unchained was better than inglorious
basterds but maybe right under Kill Bill
however this is the bloody good time you
want for Christmas if you're a Tarantino
fan you're going to be like that
Nintendo 64 kid on YouTube opening up is
a Nintendo 64 package that will be you
my friend jangle Unchained has great
dialogue great characters Christoph
Waltz is a badass Jamie Foxx is a badass
Leonardo DiCaprio is a badass samuel
l.jackson is a badass it's part bounty
hunter quest on a quest for revenge and
a quest for justice and a quest for
liberation there you go Django
Shayne is awesome tacular so what's your
favorite Tarantino movie of all time
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more